For this quiz, I want you to take
a look at the hometown hero image and
the navigation links, NEWS,
EVENTS, CULTURE, and BLOG.
Start with a small viewport and
resize the page to make it larger.
Pay attention to the size
of the hero image, and
the spacing between the nav links.
As you play with it I
want you to ask yourself,
where would you add a breakpoint?
Type your answer in here and
just to be clear,
there's not just one right answer, this
is as much of an art as it is a science.
Oh, and here's a hint, if you open
up DEV Tools and resize the page,
you'll notice that the resolution is
displayed in the top right-hand corner.
That'll help you find out where
you want to put your breakpoint.